pues raúl es cierto en los últimos días
hemos asistido a un aumento exponencial
del contagio en el país en un mes el
número de pacientes hospitalizados en
las unidades de cuidados intensivos se
ha multiplicado por 7 ayer 623 decesos
fueron registrados en 24 horas este es
el peor dato de muertos en un día desde
el pasado 6 de abril aquí en italia
lohan y a inicios del mes de septiembre
el país se parecía a lograr resistir a
la segunda ola pero ahora la realidad es
que italia está en el ojo del ciclón la
situación está completamente fuera de
control no se logra hacerle seguimiento
a los casos positivos ni a los contactos
directos de estas personas en varias
regiones principalmente en lombardía
pero también en el sur del país regiones
que cuentan con infraestructuras
sanitarias más precarias mucho menos
desarrolladas que en el norte de italia
natalia esta situación está dando lugar
a escenas dramáticas en los hospitales
italianos que ocurre realmente
pues lo que ocurre es que el sistema de
salud pública italiana está al borde del
colapso y una prueba de esto son las
imágenes que llegan de un hospital en
nápoles en donde por falta de espacio
los enfermos de coronavirus no son
atendidos dentro del hospital sino en la
calle en el parqueadero
se ve en las filas de carros parqueados
parados con los enfermos de coronavirus
acostados en los puestos de atrás en las
botellas de oxígeno acomodadas en la
calle en el andén y los enfermeros que
pasan de carro en carro controlando la
salud de los pacientes la federación
italiana de médicos y anestesistas ha
lanzado un grito de alarma reclamando
con fuerza un nuevo confinamiento
general una hipótesis que por el momento
el gobierno italiano ha rechazado
temiendo las las consecuencias nefastas
que esto pueda tener en la economía del
país